this is a pretty inspirational story
when you were a young guy you always
wanted to be a comedian or something at
15 I was writing jokes right to escape
from reality yeah cuz reality was bad
terrible were your parents horrible my
father was never home he was out looking
to make other kids right you saw you and
said I have to make more she did that's
look what do you mean by wrong seriously
values really what were her values money
well money has to make money she wanted
me to marry a rich girl and support her
right yeah so she always said to you
Rodney I want you to grow up grow up
marry a rich girl marry a rich girl
right Wow so that put a lot of pressure
on you right away and you said what kind
of values is this you should marry
someone for love or team asking girls
how much money do you couldn't believe
so your own mother in a sense you were
mad at were it true right right but but
it was shocking to you right but would
you recognize that there was something
right and we she had dissatisfied with
her life that she didn't marry a rich
man was that the thing right so at 15
you're running around you're writing
jokes at 19 that was a singing waiter no
kidding tomorrow we'll just you wait and
see
so that job didn't last long mr.
ceremonies I sang they threw money at me
so so Lenny Bruce's did you write jokes
for Lenny Bruce right so that's way back
and a genius Lenny Bruce I mean do you
like the guy nice guy yeah did you say
hey Lenny why you doing so many drugs
for did you uh
it's I had experience with him with that
would turn me off right because you
never do we're never into that scene
right little pot that's it but you've
seen tons of comics do themselves in
with drugs I mean the late Sam Kinison
who we both agree was brilliant genius
genius but the guy just couldn't get
this whole drug use thing under control
stuff you know when you had to good
something happens to you I guess when
it's tough to keep us straight you know
in show visits was anything more
brilliant than Sam's brief appearance in
your film back to school I mean was
anything the best scenes on film ever
and all his this is tremendous he was
tremendous in fact Ronny was one of the
first comics to really give Sam a break
I think that was where I first saw Sam
was on one of his specials the HBO
special
Rodney brought him out which a lot of
people know specials you know I know
every Seinfeld Roseanne Barr Tim Allen
Jeff Fox very much in the world yeah I
know about not even put all these guys
I'm happy yeah yeah was really good but
I know that's the first time I ever
heard Sam Kinison because I haven't I
think Sam consumers one the most
brilliant comics that ever lived was it
ever graced this planet and it's sad to
see him gone so all right so you this
young guy you're writing jokes for other
people but you never got up and told
jokes yourself until what age yeah that
was 1919 is when you start up joints
right right and one bouncer said to me
once I think you stink what do you want
to do about it so when you did these
gigs and you and you went around and
everything it was frustrating to you
because you felt you were funny you knew
you were a good comic and yet things
weren't breaking for you right good give
me a floor the first time then I mean
how good can you be as you get five
outlets for two shows on Saturday right
and one time the owner says me no way
this doing MC I told him here's a dime
back coffee it was a nickel that where
you looked at her Bronx for Subway
and so I said being a true thespian
right I said well can I be a waiter for
the night all right give me four tables
to back somewhere so you know the whole
thing was to make a book right and the
thing was that because the thing I
always read about you is that like right
at 40 years old you quit the business I
said that's it I can't take it I can't
make a living doing this give me an idea
while I was doing at a time I quit I was
the only one who knew like right right
there was no there was no big
announcement in the newspaper so the
thing is is that had to be frustrating
to you because inside you believed in
yourself you knew you were funny and yet
the business was being cruel to you know
something I was immature then right was
it mature had no image right so I quit
it and got married and I found out
making a marriage work as tougher to get
work in show business
make sure business look easy that's
right right so you got married and and
for a while you were like a Salesman
stuff this is inspiration and is
aluminum siding the ugliest crap in the
world or what really do you go back they
don't even care that you're a comic
funny stories I can tell you about that
weird New Jersey for 10 years did you
imagine I'll tell you so I saw people a
job in a Senate Saturday Sunday they
watching ed Sullivan and they see me
walk out on its own under a different
name
Wow my name jack reuler real name sort
of siding then they see Rodney
Dangerfield so they said she says to the
mechanic is mr. release also in show
business yeah yeah the side you know Wow
on the side that's Sullivan Sullivan's
the sign game so even when you were back
to in ed Sullivan you were still selling
the aluminum siding and people would
tune in and see they're aluminum siding
ion itself and it's a weird sort of
place to be and that you're selling
aluminum siding and you want to feel
like they're in showbiz and Sullivan let
me announce it to anybody here on
aluminum what do you really let you do
that what of what a gentleman